stäbchen recht stäbchen links engländer
teil eins morgen routine danach folgt
für die verkaufsleiterin eines
frischwaren händlers der bange blick
aufs handy
um vier uhr morgens kommen immer die
ersten textnachrichten einer sagt er ist
positiv dann gleich der nächste ein
anderer fühlt sich schlecht will besser
nicht reinkommen nichts fürchte ich so
sehr wie die zeit um vier uhr morgens
ihr test negativ doch bei jedem vierten
der 140 angestellten sieht das gerade
anders aus omikron krank zu hause die
firma liefert obst und gemüse im
großraum london aus jede neue
krankmeldung bedeutet bis zu 30
frustrierte kunden die vergeblich auf
verderbliche ware warten kamel der
geschäftsführer muss neben seinem
bürojob seit wochen auch als fahrer ran
gestern habe ich um acht uhr abends
angefangen die nacht durch bis mittags
um 14 uhr durchgearbeitet fast 20
stunden
jetzt bin ich schon wieder seit 12 uhr
gestern mittag hier keine ahnung war
nicht schluss machen kann dabei bin ich
doch der geschäftsführer und habe
wichtigeres zu tun
11 krankmeldungen an einem morgen
darunter der firmenchef elena gehen die
ideen aus wie sie die löcher stopfen
soll durch den dreck cit sei es schon so
viel schwerer geworden fahrer meist aus
osteuropa anzuheuern obendrauf corona es
geht ums überleben der firma
ich denke wir alle kriegen jetzt
umgekommen es wird sowie mit der grippe
die wirtschaft kann es sich nicht mehr
leisten dass täglich leute für eine
ganze woche ausfallen das ist
kontraproduktiv und kostet uns den
ganzen land sehr viel geld
die omikron welle dürfte jeden vierten
arbeitnehmer bis ende februar einmal
außer gefecht setzen rechnen die
regierung vor auch in den krankenhäusern
in die das militär einmarschiert im
kampf gegen den personalmangel zum glück
sei omikron milder die zahl der schweren
verläufe steige weit weniger rasant als
die fallzahlen nur deshalb dürfte das
gesundheitssystem nicht kollabieren
erklärt einer der führenden immunogen
des landes den impfstoffen sei dank ohne
sie wäre es wie in einem kriegsgebiet
absolut verheerend unsere modelle zeigen
dass durch die impfstoffe bis zu eine
million leben gerettet aber das gilt nur
für die beiden zurückliegenden jahre bei
fallzahlen wie jetzt mit omikron würden
ohne impfungen in allen krankenhäusern
europas die krankenwagen lange schlangen
bilden
es sei anders als vor einem jahr als
täglich hunderte starben sahen carlisle
fühlt sich gut geschützt dreifach
geimpft dennoch macht omikron das leben
schwer tochter lg muss rund um die uhr
betreut werden die 20 jährige leidet an
einem seltenen gendefekt im kopf wie
eine zweijährige ihre fördereinrichtung
ist bis auf weiteres jede zweite woche
geschlossen wegen personalmangel was l
wie aus dem gleichgewicht bringt
sie hat wutanfälle es müde ist
frustriert darüber dass sie nicht
mitteilen kann was sie möchte
sie schmeißt möbel um und kann sehr
aggressiv werden sie greift mich dann an
und beißt mich
ist geschieden selbstständige pr
beraterin in den wochen mit elvir liegen
die nerven blank und in ihrem job bleibt
alles liegen
es ist so unendlich niederschmetternd es
gibt sowieso schon einen mangel an
pflegekräften land die die uns in den
ferien etwa helfen und unterstützen sind
meist die assistenz lehrer die jetzt
natürlich arbeiten müssen oder ebenfalls
krank sind
der krasse personalmangel auch
hausgemacht keine größeren
einschränkungen volle stadien etwa
machen es omikron leicht doch die
fußballfans sind wie die regierung
bereit auf risiko zu spielen
ich bin dreimal geimpft und hatte davor
schon corona
es sind viel weniger
krankenhauseinweisungen und tote als
bislang wenn leute rausgehen dann
riskieren sie dass
niemand zwingt sie derzeit jeder hat
eine wahl
keine wahl mehr scheint der premier zu
haben gegen die widerstände seiner
wissenschaftlichen berater will boris
johnson ohne neue restriktionen durch
diese bälle wohl auch weil seine corona
müde partei ihn andernfalls droht fallen
zu lassen seien autoritätsverlust fast
zu ansteckend lyon micon auch beim
wähler seit wochen dominieren
enthüllungen über vermeintliche partys
im amts- und wohnsitz des premiers die
schlagzeilen mindestens elfmal sollen
corona verbote intern downing street
gebrochen worden seien johnson soll mit
gefeiert haben der premier entschuldigte
sich am mittag er verstehe die wut
vieler landsleute aber aber geglaubt es
handelte sich um erlaubte arbeitstreffen
zeit zu gehen findet nicht nur der
oppositionsführer während das ganze land
im lock down ist gibt er feucht
fröhliche partys in downing street wird
er jetzt das einzig anständige tun und
zurücktreten
ob johnson der zocker politisch
überleben kann offen zumindest scheint
ihm das glück in sachen omikron holt die
fallzahlen sinken die welle scheint
heftig aber kurz hohe impfquoten viele
genesene kroner könnte endemisch werden
ein virus das uns begleitet 1 unter
vielen
ich habe mein leben in der medizinischen
forschung in de mission krankheiten
gewidmet die tuberkulose hiv malaria
millionen menschen töten endemisch ist
nicht gleichbedeutend mit mild oder gut
es bedeutet dass da etwas im hintergrund
lauert jederzeit bereit dich zu töten
neue gefährliche varianten können weiter
auftauchen ergänzt ordnen die folgen von
longo wird würden noch erforscht es sei
zu früh für entwarnung elena ist trotz
aller vorsicht optimistisch die korona
bedingten personalengpässe werden schon
aufhören omikron sei unangenehm aber
aushaltbar als es mit corona losging
wussten wir nichts über das virus wie
tödliches ist das war schlimmer als
jetzt nun werden wir lernen damit zu
leben
sie hätten ja viel vitamin c um sich
scherzt elena zum ende ihrer schicht mal
wieder sorgenfrei ausschlafen ohne tests
durchs leben das sie hoffentlich nicht
mehr allzu weit weg